[Music]
thank you hello and welcome to a very
special edition of not the week in 60
minutes but the year in 60 minutes
brought to you by spectator TV and
broadcast on Thursday the 15th of
December
it's been quite a year and there's a lot
to talk about so we are going to go
through the key events of the last 12
months with our chairman the great
Andrew Neal and the novelist and great
spectator columnist Lionel Shriver
we will then go to Ukraine where we will
talk to the novelist Andre kirchhoff
about what has been going on there in
the last 12 months
after that we will be coming back to
England to talk to our columnist Rob
little about wokery
what exactly it is and whether it really
exists at all
from Rod the bogeyman we will move to
fungus the bogeyman I will be talking
about the late great illustrator Raymond
Briggs who died in August Raymond Briggs
was most famously the creator of the
Snowman which a lot of people watch at
Christmas
I will be talking to Juliet Nicholson
the author about her late friend
and finally I will be resisting the urge
to snog The Spectator contributor and
comedian Andrew Watts as we talk about
mistletoe
before we get going I would like to urge
you all to subscribe to spectator TV
which I'm sure you'd like to do you can
do that by hitting the Subscribe button
at the bottom of the screen and then
clicking the Bell icon at the top of the
screen to make sure you never ever miss
an episode
I should also alert you to our spectator
Christmas offer uh which is that for 12
pounds just 12 pounds you will get 12
weeks of The Spectator in print and
online and we will throw in with
extraordinary generosity a bottle of
Paul Roger champagne
just go to spectator.co.uk forward slash
Santa to take advantage of that offer
well we are now approaching the end of
2022 and what a year it's been
I don't think I'm being excessively
gloomy in saying that a lot of very bad
things have happened we've had the war
in Ukraine we've had an inflation crisis
and an energy crisis we've had the death
of the queen and Chaos in Westminster
and we've also had the threat the
looming threat and indeed the reality
now of strikes
I'm joined Now by Andrew Neal our
chairman and our columnist Lionel
Shriver to look back at an extraordinary
2022.
Andrew I'll start with you
uh a lot of people talking about strikes
at the moment uh and there's often this
phrase the winter of discontent and the
newspapers often suggest that we are
going through the 1970s again do you
think such talk is exaggerated
uh yes the only people who are comparing
it to the 1970s never lived through the
1970s and you you just have to look at a
chart of strikes just to take one metric
uh and Strikes in the 70s they're
massive compared to now I mean it is
true that we're in probably the more
strikes in 10 years uh though we've yet
to reach a stage where any of these
Strikers really win and I noticed that
even Mr Lynch of the rmt is getting
increasingly irascible in broadcast
interviews which suggest to me that he
thinks he's going to lose now I did warn
him in July of this year that he didn't
have the power he thought he had that
working from home had changed all that
and that the rails were not as essential
as before so yeah it's been a pretty
Grim year I agree with that but it's
nothing like the 70s in Britain we've
not had to call in the IMF whereas we
did in the 70s there aren't strikes
every day and the unions win every
strike which happened in the 70s that's
not happening inflation has not reached
25 percent which it did in the 1970s
even though it's high and interest rates
last time I looked I still want around
two percent two and a half percent
whereas uh then in these days there were
over 20 so you know and Jimmy Carter had
just come down from the mountain known
as Camp David to say that America was a
gripped in a malaise America has a lot
of problems but it's not quite a malays
at the moment so it's not it's difficult
it's tough it's tough for people to live
through these times it's a difficult
compared to Years Gone by and I think I
I would also I think the reason why it
seems
so Grim is that this was really meant to
be the year where we we on both sides of
the Atlantic we boomed back from the
pandemic it was to be back to normality
growth would return Prosperity would
return and the combination of the war in
Ukraine and inflation uh which are
linked
um has meant that we've not boomed back
at all in fact we're kind of treading
water
Lionel do you think um our industry the
media I know you're a novelist but you
also do with the media
um uh do you think we're to blame
slightly for creating this climate of uh
Gloom I mean I keep reading about
General strikes and there's never hasn't
been a general strike since 1926 I think
uh and there's this sort of sense that
actually is it really a general stroke
because actually as Andrew says it's not
really in the same sense
um are we journalists to blame for
creating this climate of of despair
I think that might be giving journalists
a little too much credit right I mean
everything that we're talking about is
real and not the invention of the media
um and
there even if the strikes are not as
terrible as they were in the 1970s
um what is driving the strikes is is
substantial I mean it's uh for one thing
it's the consequence of of the lockdown
policies and the extravagant amounts of
money we spent on absolutely nothing
during that period
and it seemed at first as if we were
going to get away with it and that it
was like oh that that's fine the
economy's bounced right back and and
there was nothing wrong with having that
response to covet because because we
haven't suffered any consequences and
then it will it because economics is a
slow lumbering beast and it you know the
results take a while to show up and
they're showing up
um there's a way in which the war in
Ukraine is is doing politicians a favor
because it helps disguise the fact that
a lot of this inflation is
um not uh due to Russia's Invasion but
it is due to the excesses of pandemic
response and
um you can see that in the the
creeping up of inflation well before
February 24th
Andrew I take Lionel's point that
journalists probably shouldn't
exaggerate uh how important we are in
the world but perhaps what I was getting
is maybe social media uh since everyone
is a journalist in a way on social media
uh and that contributes Twitter in
particular to a kind of Hysteria about
things and a lack of a sense of
perspective
yes I mean I think you know we
journalists we do like bad news uh
because for some reason we think it
sells uh or maybe it's just more
dramatic than good news uh and uh and
social media
has that in Spades I mean it amplifies
bad news no one on social media or very
few people actually tweet good news
there is one web there is one uh Twitter
feed uh in Britain which does announce
Jefferson I think is called announces
you know new investments in British
industry and uh new infrastructure and
so on it's like a lone voice it's a one
little ray of sunshine in a whole
Twitter feed of misery uh there and I
think that has helped to amplify there
is also a a particularly British
characteristic of work here it's not
true where I am at the moment on the
American side of the Atlantic which is
that there's a whole industry in Britain
doing ourselves down
uh indeed there are some people are
never happy unless they're doing
ourselves down unless they're doing the
country down and I think the whole
brexit debate made that worse because
the the remainers
um they want to be Vindicated in the
stands they took and they want the
breakfast tears to be proved wrong and
so much is still seen through this prism
of remain or leave and they want Britain
to fail because that will vindicate the
decision they took to vote not to leave
and show that all these brexiteers were
wrong and what they did so that's added
to the the general predisposition of the
British chattering classes to do the
country down
well Andrew I'll stay with you you are
in New York at the moment uh the latest
economic news for America seems to be a
little bit uh more cheerful uh inflation
seems to be coming down uh do you get a
sense that uh that can do American
Spirit is still there and they feel that
next year is going to be a a year in
which America bounces back
where I am it's not in New York I mean
New York is a shadow of its former self
at the moment it's a part of it like a
shanty town it's quite you know it's a
city I love and I've been coming here
and living here over and on since 1976
and it's back to the segment we talked
about the 70s New York in many ways is
back to the 70s it's dilapidated It's
Shabby he's got people shouting at you
in the streets it's got a threatening
sense to it again crime is Right Rising
the place is filthy retail stores are
closed I mean I'm not in exactly the
poorest part of New York I'm in Midtown
and I just need to go up to 2nd Avenue
and every second retail unit is closed I
mean you the contrast with London is
quite dramatic I mean you in London now
you almost really wouldn't know there
had been a pandemic uh London is just
kind of back to normal now New York is
not back to normal at all and loose to
me it will be it's actually got more
decline in it before we get back to that
that but as we all know New York is not
America and other parts of America are
doing well outside the big cities the
country is coming back and I think as
always you know new America was kind of
first into this recession I don't think
the recession will be very deep and it
will be first out inflation is beginning
to come down there's been a huge you add
Mr Trump and Mr Biden together there's
been an incredible amount of Keynesian
pump priming which contributed as like I
was saying to inflation you can't blame
it all in the uh the war that's for sure
uh in Ukraine
um but I do think America will come out
of it uh more quickly and help to drag
up the rest of the world economy because
where else where else are we going to
get this growth it ain't coming from
Europe that's for sure Europe is adding
for a serious recession China is in its
94th lockdown
um and actually its economy is really
stuttering now you can forget get all
predictions that China will overtake the
American economy in this decade in size
that ain't going to happen so I think
it's good that America will begin to get
its act together again
let's keep with America but move to
politics uh the last time I think I
spoke to you on spectator TV was after
the midterms and you were in quite a
good mood because uh not just because
the Red Wave hadn't happened but because
uh trumpist candidates as many people
have noticed got defeated all the Senate
candidates in particular were defeated
uh does that give you calls for optimism
in 2023 that uh certainly the American
right might return to something you
regard more as sanity
well the statistics would not bear that
out
not yet you know
if you look at the polls of Republican
voters the majority of them still
support Trump and the real question is
whether or not they come to their senses
in time and there's not very much time
left uh
a year from now
I think that the party has to have some
sense of resolution about which
direction they're going and what's
really frustrating is that you know they
have they have a wide open door in the
White House the the Republicans could
simply walk away with the executive
branch
24 if they just ran someone who wasn't
Trump
the the this Trump thing is is a
drive to self-destruction and
um
I
honestly I am certain DeSantis could do
it there are probably a number of
candidates who can do it I think that
DeSantis is probably the the best bet
but I feel that there's a funny kind of
clock ticking little by little
uh Trump supporters are somewhat reduced
in number and nothing happens in the
news in relation to that guy that would
you would think increases support aside
from of this whole persecution problem
and that's that's one thing that he's
capitalizing on now so that despite the
fact that he's a former president of the
United States he's running as an
underdog and that that
you know that plays into the natural
paranoia of his supporters because they
they do think that the world is against
them and that
um most of what's most of Trump's
Shenanigans are due to you know the FBI
and every other deep State organization
coming after him
um
you know I I I I I don't like personally
as a former Biden voter it looks you
know I don't want him to run again I
don't want and that's true that makes me
like the majority of the country it's
something like three quarters of
American voters say they don't want
either one of those two elderly
gentlemen to be running again and I you
know I have
tremendous concerns about Biden's uh
mental facilities and they're certainly
not going to be getting any better by
the time he's 86.
I
I had concerns about Trump and and just
how much he may have deteriorated
because if you look at earlier
recordings of trump when he was younger
he was far more articulate he spoke in
complete sentences and he didn't use the
same word over and over again it uh he
himself has also degenerated and you
know it's a big country and we can do
better
but you know it is not impossible from
this perspective that we end up with
another Trump Biden
election in 24 and I just
what's wrong with us
well let's cross back uh across the
Atlantic and talk about Westminster
because after all London we've had a
pretty crazy year in British politics
too we've had uh three prime ministers
we've lost count of how many chances so
much so that at The Spectator Awards
recently our parliamentarian Awards we
had a chancellor of the year uh award
um I wonder to you uh probably a bit of
a silly question but um which politics
seems crazier uh to you as an American
in Britain British or American
I'm sorry I really have to opt for the
Americans
I was hoping that that would push us
towards the conversation about Britain
but okay we can go back to America
the shenanigans in the UK are on a
completely different and I have to say
lesser scale it's it's
a great consequence in in the big
picture and even the uh markets
overreaction towards trust uh that has
settled down and I don't think it has
had huge long-term uh consequences those
interest rates were going up anyway
so uh I I think that on on the level of
crazy we have you beat it's you don't
have anyone uh like Trump in the wings
threatening to take over the country
everyone is relatively credible
that's that's no doubt true but uh
Andrew I mean that it hasn't been a good
year for the Tory party I think that's a
fair thing to say We'll file that we'll
file that under British understatement
so uh I think
um I mean can Rishi sunak turn it around
for the Tory party or is Labor's lead
now unassailable going into the next
general election
there's an outside chance he can turn
around I don't think you can count that
out the country's not actually actually
gagging for Kia St Arma
um but it's probably not likely that he
wins the election so much as the Tories
lose it uh so he could turn it around if
he can get into if we can get out of the
recession get on top of inflation get
some growth back living standards Rising
again get out of this cost of living
crisis then I wouldn't count count it
out but there is a mountain to climb I
mean it's perfectly possible in
retrospect that uh historians will say
2022 was the year the Tories lost to the
election uh you know because they've
just been self-indulgent and concerned
with their own internal tribal divisions
and they seem to have lost any purpose
for governing the country you know what
what's the purpose of a touring
government now uh except to do lots of
non-tory things like raise taxes to the
highest level in 70 years it seems like
a government
this just got to run out of steam and
and even a new leader like Mr sunac who
is bright and uh has lots of attractions
I think you know he seems to be he's a
bright guy he seems a nice guy but he's
yet to give them a sense of purpose he's
yet to reinvigorate the government which
new leaders can do I mean even John
Major not exactly the most invigorating
character
taking over from Margaret Thatcher he
did invigorate the Tories by enough uh
to win the 1992 election but there's no
sign that Mr sunak does that yet I'm I
remember in 1979 after uh five years of
uh rather desolatory labor government
Jim Callaghan who was the Prime Minister
and he was up against Margaret Thatcher
in the spring of 79 or early summer of
79 and as people were debating in his
inner circle could he beat Thatcher the
polls were not that much against him he
said there just comes a time when the
the whole atmosphere turns against you
that when the just the the climate is
against you it doesn't matter what you
do you're not going to win that turned
out to be true in 79 it was definitely
true in 97 when John Major lost by a
landslide to Tony Blair the danger for
the Tories is it's now true for Mr
sunac's stories
a lot of people saying Andrew that um
you know uh reformist party the Reform
Party populist parties on the right may
now have a Resurgence because brexit had
sort of shot the ukip fox but now
um an angry right is re-emerging do you
see signs of that no I don't actually uh
I don't see signs of that and I think
it's wishful thinking on the Hardline
brexiteers
um I'm also not sure that Mr farage
wants to leave his rather comfortable
perch in a 24-hour news station which
earns him a lot of money to go and do
that I don't see any I think beyond the
sort of square mile where you are
Freddie nobody wants to relitigate that
referendum nobody wants to go back
through the brexit the remainder leave
arguments most people just for good or
ill they just want to move on the cards
have the LIE where they lie and we just
need to get on with it and interesting
that is the view of kirst armor as well
he doesn't want to breathe there are
people around him would love to do it
he's not going to do it so I think no
the the Reform Party is not going to
have a demonstrable influence on British
politics uh that it hopes it it might
have I think it's back in England at
least it's back to labor conservative
even the lib Dems really don't seem to
be making much of a breakthrough because
Mr starmer has made it possible for lib
damn minded people to vote labor again
they don't need to vote for the leader
of the liberal Democrats who I can just
remember Mr Davey
um and what are the interesting things
too is that if it is time if it's
Labor's turn again
that cauterizes Sidelines the whole
Scottish separatist movement
because it is much harder to run a
separatist campaign against the labor
government in London than a conservative
government in London so you know I think
there are
quite big changes uh quite Watershed
events about to happen in Britain as a
result of the way things are at the the
moment I would say it's
three four to one against the Tories
winning the next election but
we know things can change and you know
we live in you know who would have seen
the Ukraine war coming I mean I was very
optimistic about the economy of this
year but on both sides of the Atlantic I
saw growth returning investment
returning and all the rest of it
Lionel's right inflation was starting to
rise and central banks made a terrible
call uh on that and we've all suffered
for that but I still thought there would
be some growth and I never saw the
Ukraine war there are just what was it
Don rumsfels I think that was one of
these unknown unknowns
yeah
let us wrap this up uh if I may
uh on on an attempt at a more cheerful
note because Christmas is supposed to be
a source of uh optimism for Humanity
uh Andrew uh in our Christmas edition uh
I'll start with you Andrew in our
Christmas edition we asked various
contributors including uh the Dalai Lama
amazingly enough uh if uh what gives
them hope
um so I wonder Andrew going into 2023
what gives you hope
well I don't know what the daylight Lama
said but whatever he said I agree with
I've interviewed him he's the most
impressive person I've ever interviewed
uh and you're speaking to the least
spiritual person in the world here
um listen I've here's the thing
I think Ukraine is good in 2023 Ukraine
is going to win the war what does wind
look like that's debatable but for sure
Russia ain't going to win it and I think
Ukraine wins it and it will be a
terrible defeat for Russia and suddenly
things will get back to normal and we'll
be pouring resources into Ukraine to
help build it I think inflation will
come down much more quickly than the
forecasters say just as it went up much
more quickly than the forecasters uh
thought indeed if you begin to look at
uh towards the end of 2024 or 25 you
begin to see deflation beginning to take
a grip but for a while as inflation
plummets it'll make us feel better it'll
raise our living sons and will come out
of the cost of living and a crisis and
if people start to spend more again then
growth returns to the economy so I don't
despair you know both as journalists and
uh as politicians
we find it very hard to to discern when
the trend we're living through comes to
an end and we kind of act as if trees
grow to the sky that you know inflation
is now double digit is always going to
be double digits where uh we've got no
growth we're going to have no growth for
the foreseeable future I think there'll
be quite a dramatic turnaround led by
America uh in in the economic Outlook
and that so I am more positive on the
economical Outlook in as 2023 proceeds
we're heading into recession there's no
doubt about that but I don't think it's
going to be that deep all that long and
I think as prices start to fall more
quickly than the forecasters thing can
you really begin to see a bit of that in
America now as well the the economic
optimism will return so I don't think
there's a need for Endless Gloom however
much some people need to feel they
should be an endless Gloom just to keep
them happy
thank you Andrew you've cheered me up
which is almost impossible at the moment
uh Lionel what gives you hope
um I've been much cheered by what's been
going on in China
um on on multiple levels I mean it is
satisfying as someone who has opposed
covid lockdowns from the very beginning
to see uh that policy taken to the Max
and to see it fail it doesn't work and
lockdown came from China and it's dying
in China it's also a relief to see the
Chinese people
be able to draw a line and say enough is
enough
I think we in the west often
write the Chinese off is just hopelessly
compliant and they'll do whatever
they're told they've been turned into
little automatons but they're not
and uh and you know they suffer under a
huge amount of control and oppression
and and someone is always watching them
I don't feel envious
but there have been a lot of people who
have now stuck their necks out and and
even in defiance of such would be
absolute control say we're not taking
this anymore and I I think that's a
really good sign so it's it's good for
uh the spectacle uh uh internationally
of a highly destructive uh response to
disease it's it's good that it it looks
bad I was
amused how many Western media Outlets
responded to the Chinese protests so
it's like oh of course you know this
policy is terrible it doesn't work
where were you two years ago you
bastards oh
and I I also think that what's going on
in Iran is is is cheerful I mean amid
amidst a lot of horror I mean they're
they're now starting to execute
protesters but this is again this is a
it's mostly young women who will not
take it anymore
and and
um I think that uh it's it's been well
observed that the left and the West
doesn't seem remotely interested which
is bizarre I mean when you think about
well isn't this the ultimate me too
patriarchy
um where where you have to go around you
know
in a bin liner I mean it's it
it's a horribly repressive regime for
for women in particular and it's bizarre
to me that the women's movement in the
west is not interested
but I'm interested and and I really wish
them the best I mean I am a little
skeptical because so many of these
revolutions come to nothing think the
Arab Spring but but before
this one also comes to nothing I'm going
to be optimistic
well I can't think of a better note to
end it on uh
sorry uh
thank you very much very happy Christmas
to you guys thank you Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas to you too now of course
one of the most distressing stories of
this year has been the war in Ukraine
and we are delighted to be joined Now by
Andre kirkov who is uh Ukraine's
greatest living novelist I think I may
say and he has written a brilliant
notebook in the Christmas edition about
life in his village of lazarifka which
is 50 miles from Kiev I think I'm
writing saying Andre yes that's right
and you're there at the moment
um first of all I want to ask because I
uh I spoke to Ukrainian last night who
was quite surprised at how cold it was
in Britain and I thought it was very old
because I always assumed that Ukraine is
much much colder is it very cold there
right now uh today it is only minus one
I mean we had several all this with plus
five plus seven Centigrade where the
rain fog but now it's back to frost and
it was even Sunny for a couple of hours
today I also want to ask you about uh
what the atmosphere is like in in your
village because
um obviously last year you a lot of
people were anticipating War uh and
ukrainians in particular are
anticipating it I believe
um how has the year changed uh your view
of things are you more optimistic about
2023 are you optimistic for peace next
year
oh it's difficult to talk about optimism
but people are looking forward to the
end of this year so I mean the main idea
is to say goodbye to this year the war
became some sort of banality because
people actually don't talk much about
the war since I mean when they want to
know something they watch TV or they go
into news
so so I mean I I didn't talk during my
last three days with neighbors about the
war at all and we were talking about
food I was helping my neighbor Nina to
go to the nearest town to buy food for
her chickens today and then I had coffee
in the vegetable shop in Brazil and also
I mean I talked to shop assistant and
she didn't mention the war because I
mean it's probably upsetting if you
start talking about the war but of
course I mean ukrainians are hoping that
the war will be over next year and it's
interesting that regularly in the news
we have some quotations from American or
British Army generals who are saying
that Ukrainian Army will free Crimea by
August next year or that uh keroson
region will be completely freed by May
or June so I mean this is kind of
injections of I don't know justifiable
or not justifiable optimism probably
lifts up the the mood to feed the
festive mood of the Christmas that is
coming
and do do you think uh that I mean
president zielinski has become a sort of
global hero and so on but before the war
started uh ukrainians weren't terribly
sure about him were they
oh they were not sure and I I don't know
if they are sure about him now but
majority of ukrainians support of course
support him and most of the politicians
are united uh because I mean because of
the common enemy because of the uh
common danger uh to the existence of of
Ukraine once the war is over I think the
opinions will be divided again but
anyway I mean he is doing good job I
mean he managed to sort of
almost to organize some kind of army
Detachment from the heads of foreign
States so they have been he is talking
to them every day they are promising
more
ammunition and more weapons and actually
this weapon is coming so uh everything
is functioning but I mean one should
also accept that the the Russian army
which was considered to be one of the
most professional ones is also becoming
more professional in in in this war so
it's I think it's more and more
difficult to fight against uh Russians
you are a native Russian speaker and uh
I think um I'm rising saying that a lot
of native Russian ukrainians or people
who spoke Russian first in Ukraine
um have been uh United to Ukraine more
through the War I I spoke to uh uh a
Ukrainian
um oligarch uh Dimitri fertesh who said
that Putin had achieved the one thing
that no one else could do and that was
United of Ukraine would you agree with
that assessment
I would agree but I would actually
probably add that uh what happened that
Russian speakers got extremely uh
disunity disconnected with everything
Russian
and many of Russian speakers started
speaking Ukrainian
um more often or just purposely forget
in Russian language it depends on the
situation because I mean I met people
who always spoke Russian and who lost
everything in donbass in mariopal and
they started speaking actually Ukrainian
with each other the family and they
never spoke Ukrainian before I mean they
understood it now they are learning they
are practicing it
so uh I think uh one of the most evident
victims of this war will be Russian
language in Ukraine
and is that a sadness for you
well it is uh it was sad when I was
thinking about this in the beginning
uh but uh I'm not paying too much
attention to this issue because I mean
this is not the most important victim
the most important victim is actually
Ukraine itself Ukrainian families that
lost everything that lost loved ones the
Ukrainian soldiers of whom probably
about 15 20 000 uh killed now and much
more wounded so so I mean
it's no sense to feel sorry for the
language and especially since actually
this war destroyed the notion of Russian
culture itself
so I don't think Russian culture will
mean the same now also outside Russia
and Ukraine in in in in Britain in
Europe in America
after this war because I mean you cannot
associate culture with uh this kind of
monster that Russia managed to become
well that's interesting do you I mean is
it because would it would it not be more
normal to fixate on Putin and the
Kremlin Administration rather than
Russian culture as a broader thing
no I mean I I think it's it's uh
important to understand that Russian
culture was an is instrumentalized by
Putin and the political Elite and
actually on even on local level I mean
in the beginning of the war uh Ministry
of culture of Russian Federation sent
official letters to the libraries asking
them to organize activities to support
Russian army in Ukraine and what did
they do I mean they involved Pushkin
Dostoyevsky and Tolstoy in this War I
mean they decorated monuments to Pushkin
with a Russian army memorabilia with the
Zed letters with some kind of Medals of
the Russian army so for me it's the same
and actually since majority of Russian
regulations supported the war and they
are so anti-ukrainian anti-American
anti-western so I think we have a right
to talk about Russian culture as part of
today's Russian state
well I wondered uh finally are you
working on a new novel at the moment I
assume you probably are and if so are uh
Ukrainian nationalist themes or
patriotic themes uh uh emerging in your
work
I'm not writing a novel unfortunately
I'm in a interrupted work on my novel
about 1919 in Kiev in the beginning of
the award the first day of the war and I
didn't manage to get back to work I mean
I'm still writing essays and articles
and my Diaries and I'm dreaming of
actually restarting the novel that I put
aside but the story in the novel will
not be changed actually it's a it's a
historical crime novel set in the Civil
War time that lasted four years from
1918 till 1921 and which had a lot of
things which are happening now I mean it
was the same kind of uh violence with
which Uh Russian army at that time Red
Army the bolsheviki came to Ukraine from
the same North Eastern side from Bella
Russian side and they did actually in
Kiev in 1918 the same that that a
Russian army did in Butcher and European
in February March this year so it's not
actually about patriotism it's about the
history repeating itself
well Andre Kirko thank you very much for
joining us I hope that you have a happy
Christmas whichever day you celebrated
on and I hope as well that you get to
restart your novel in a peaceful 2023
thank you very much Happy Christmas to
you too
now since it is Christmas uh we thought
we would give our viewers what they want
and we know what they want because they
put it in the comments a lot and that
what they want is more Rod little
so as a Christmas tree here he is our
health and wellness correspondent Rod
little uh who has a typically brilliant
column uh in our Christmas edition about
wokery
um Rod I thought I'd start by saying
because we have a bit of a um debate in
the office about whether to use the word
woke
um because on one hand it seems to have
degenerated into a meaningless term of
abuse
um and on the other it's a very useful
catch-all uh for a lot of the things
that are most awful about the world uh
you clearly have decided you will use it
but do you know what I mean when I say
that it's different I know exactly what
you mean it's an awful word and it
doesn't quite uh Express what we mean
when we say it uh Progressive politics
is one way around it identitarian
politics is another way around it though
that doesn't quite get you into the uh
the decolonization stuff quite so easily
and the thrashing of the nation's
history I mean the reason I use it and
you used it in this particular uh pieces
is that everyone understands it yeah
everyone knows what I mean uh there are
other words wank for example is one such
and I did once use that but um
any four letter word beginning with w
indeed
well as you say in the column it is not
uh cultural Marxism is it even though a
lot of people particularly right Wingers
like to say that it is
something to do with cultural Marxism as
I say in the column you know Marx was I
don't have a huge amount of love for
Karl Marx but you could not argue with
being anything other than both an
empiricist
and
a communitarian I mean those two things
uh but he is rather famously both of
those two things whereas whereas World
Korean identity politics is kind of
post-rational and uh has no time for
empiricism whatsoever and it's of course
by definition individualistic
I suppose what people are getting at
there is that they think it's a sort of
uh it's on it's on a mission to March
through the institutions and Destroy
them all
yeah yeah it's it's the old gramsky's
saying sure but they also mean that it's
left-wing you know it's a bit like
anyone who's accused of being right wing
eventually the the uh the comparison
stretches back to Hitler so it is with
with anything on the left uh if you wish
to denigrate it you say it's Marxist
um uh and that so that's about as far as
it goes I mean there is some truth
that the Frankfurt School hawkenheimer
uh particularly
um habermas Marcus
there's something in there which feeds
in without question to what we call
wokism
um largely a sense of a disdain of
Bourgeois moral values
um and a dislike of any form of
authority and this in injunction that
one had to express oneself Christ
there's anything done us more damage
than that expressing oneself so so there
is a little bit of that in there but I
also think by the same token there's a
little bit of the of the Frankfurt of
the of The Chicago School of economics
in there which was also very very
individualistic and uh did away with the
notion of society but didn't really
agree with Society or thought it was
something that one should stay away from
for tour possible and was it was about
you know but that was largely about
money but nonetheless it was very very
individualistic I don't think it's a
surprise of both on left and right the
dominant
uh ideologies post World War II have
been away from the communitarian and
towards the individualistic
well and and on that all getting a bit
heavy isn't it no I'm liking it I like
it yeah you're saying it very well I'm
learning a lot
um I I mean on the individualistic stuff
I mean it's also let's keep it heavy for
a while it's also about relativism isn't
it
and Charlie uh and I I think I think it
was uh Richard hogger who who first
I first read actually noticed this
tendency in in British life and Western
life
towards a kind of vapid and vacant moral
relativism
and which you hear these days uh
from skanks and more Runners when they
say things like don't judge me that
don't don't judge me
well I will judge you you skank I will
judge you
and you cannot stop me doing so but no
you're right it's it's a moral
relativism
um but I mean more crucially than
anything what wokery is and is something
which cannot be challenged
because it's all based upon personal
experience it's my lived experience
that's that's my lift experience uh and
well now this is my Truth uh so so it's
something which you cannot challenge
rationally or empirically and it it it's
very clear about that I mean you know uh
it was the uh one of the boards which
advises Britain's University said it
wished to get University teaching away
from from european-based rational
discourse I mean they're very very clear
that it's not rational and of course
when you when you look at all the
different strands the intersectional all
those all the strands of workism
um many of them contradict each other
you know it's it's hilarious well one
thing I did want to challenge you on
slightly uh is that you say it's a
Christian well I'm going to challenge
you you're going to get offended
uh you say that worker is a creature of
affluence uh because nobody in Somalia
or Chad gets terribly worked up if you
misgender them I wanted to ask abroad
have you ever tried to misgender anyone
in Somalia or Chad because I have a
sneaking feeling that they might be
quite offended I don't think they would
be at all uh what what I mean I mean
that was a that was a
um a way of capturing the fact that
there is no wokism in those countries
and there isn't it
so don't sit there pretending there is
and Frederick okay don't try and pretend
to me that in South Sudan they're
terribly worried about trans quotas for
the next person to you know become
Village Elder and chop off someone's
head they are they are not bothered
about that I think if you kept calling
the village Elder a woman he might get
quite cross if you get but anyway I'm
being uh facetious so
you're being impish yeah impish how dare
I
um let's go to on to religion because
that's an important part of your piece
and your thesis uh which is that um
workery is a sort of it has filled the
void of religion if you like well except
it hasn't I mean it hasn't really filled
the void because it because the thing
which religion gave us was
some easily uh understandable perhaps
simplistic uh Commandments by which we
ought to live our lives as well as stuff
like you know uh the Notions of deferred
gratification the benefits of of working
hard the benefits of saving money and
and of uh and of doing good in this life
uh the religion game is all of that and
we've retreated from religion you know
we're now effectively a secular country
I don't think wokism has filled the void
I don't think anything has felt divided
you know I spoke to Charles Murray that
the sociologist the American sociologist
a while ago
uh and he told me uh at the end of that
conversation he said I'm very interested
in Europe you know this is a continent
which is abolished God and it would be
interesting to see what what they put in
its place and the answer is nothing you
know uh nothing at all
um so I I think we've
I think the retreat of religion or the
retreat of us from religion has been one
of the things which has fed into the
rise of wokery
um
almost infinite number of other things
which have fell into it my father used
to say that we have uh externalized uh
well traditionally we used to
externalize religion and internalize
morality and nowadays we do the opposite
is it because we've been doing that for
decades now that we have wokery
um were the courses as I say I think the
causes of right career are many many
fold and and you know touch on such
things as the reform of the divorce laws
the movement of women into the labor
market uh the way in which we teach
children in schools the growth of human
resources for of Human Resources the HR
departments the gross the growth of
health and safety legislation all these
things have fed into it uh my point is
that we've kind of
is that we've kind of uh built rokery
ourselves and now the recipients of it
so we've
um we only have ourselves to blame
um in terms of you're suggesting that
these days we
um externalize morality yes so we we put
it on other people but not ourselves
yeah I think I think there's there's
some truth in that there's some truth in
that
um but what we've also done is
the the great Mantra of the last 40
years is to remove stigma
so we we try to remove stigma from
people who have mental illnesses we
remove stigma from single mothers we
remove stigma these days from uh the
morbidly obese and the problem is that
stigma is is you know a useful societal
tool for preventing antisocial Behavior
Uh and if you remove stigma as we have
seen the numbers of people who are
morbidly obese or or are single mothers
will grow exponentially and they have I
mean actually in the case of single
mothers exponentially in its proper term
um so so we cannot bear this is part of
the moral relativism stuff which is we
cannot bear to judge other people on
their Lifestyles because we're all
individuals and Society doesn't really
matter it's the such a mantra in a way
um so no one can be judged and we can't
say to them you're doing wrong you're
doing something which will deeply harm
yourself harm your children and harm
Society where we're not allowed to say
that anymore
well if if it is inadequate as a
replacement religion do you think it
will collapse quite quickly uh and that
something else uh possibly is long will
spring up in its place
well Islam's Islam
um
Islam has
continued to exist as a consequence of
its refusal to change with uh
shifting morals
um and in a way that the Church of
England has tried to survive
and is not doing so at the moment by
accommodating
um new social morals
um so yeah I think there is and not
necessarily Islam but but certainly if
you look at the religious religions
which are growing in in this country it
tends to be the
the
somewhat robust side of protestantism
you know they're the pentecostalists uh
pentecostalists are thriving
uh you know and growing growing by the
growing by the months uh whereas the the
Lily liver Church of England is is in
kind of terminal decline as is sadly for
me
um uh a church which once
did know about morality and that's a
Methodist Church but it's also become
very very Lefty and woke
one uh thing you put you've got a list
of things which you've mentioned
slightly there about uh things that have
sort of contributed towards the rise of
work the diminution of marriage under
the reform of the divorce laws uh the
lack of an external threat to this
country I was very interested by that no
well yeah that's that's I mean if you
know your sociology right back to
durkheim uh one of the first major
sociological studies Emerald durkheim
study of suicide
uh which tends not to happen when
countries are at War
people tend not to kill themselves uh
there is a sense
yeah absolutely
um but but the point is that we'd emerge
1945 from a war in which we in which the
overriding message was one of
communitarianism that we're all in this
together uh that we all fight together
that we do our duty uh and that we're
doing that we're fighting for something
rather Noble and
um what you tended to get uh is is much
less mental health uh um many much fewer
mental health problems amongst the
population of fewer suicides a greater
sense of togetherness a great sense of
pulling together
um whereas the generation which follows
that which is both the Puma generation
and indeed the generations uh Generation
X sound Generation Z and the Millennials
haven't had that I mean to a degree the
Boomers have a kind of existential
threat hanging over their heads in terms
of nuclear warfare
which produced a slightly different
response to actually being bombed the
fear of being bombed is is different to
actually being bombed I think
um but but no I I think
um because we've been safe I'm not
suggesting that we should have a good
War Freddy or anything like that that
would do it I'm just saying any more
than I'm saying that you know we
shouldn't have had women into the work
workplace uh but I mean that would be an
absurdity to say that what I'm saying is
that these things have in their own way
contributed towards a more
individualistic society and awoken
Society
do you think it might explain why we're
perhaps lusting after a threat which
might explain some of the pandemic
response uh possibly the sort of almost
uh bizarre wish that Putin was posing a
nuclear threatenation nuclear threat
well I I think I think there's a few
things we're probably not associated
with vocalism going on with with Russia
uh partly I think it's a sense of
comfort
amongst the military establishment to
enter a degree the politicians that
we're fighting an enemy we understand
uh once again whereas you know previous
to that our biggest threats seemed to
come from uh radical Islam and we didn't
have a clue about how to deal with that
um so I think there's a degree of
comfort there
um and and also a slight smugness that
actually the Russians aren't very good
uh
despite despite their history
um so I think that's a I think there's
also something
um which which kind of touches on what
you were saying the
Slavic often often says and said about
smoking actually which is that
we we have outlawed racism and sexism
and uh homophobia and islamophobia but
we still need someone to hate uh and and
uh slavov suggested that smokers were
one of them and I think is right I think
you know that's an easy thing to hate
but I think for wokery some of it is
down to a middle class which isn't
allowed to hate anything else and since
it's rather bad to hate things at least
I can hate the lower classes with their
awful awful views about things as such
as transgenderism and immigration
rod that's been a very jolly section uh
appropriate to Christmas uh Happy
Christmas Fred happy Christmas thank you
for putting on tinsel
all obvious could have wanted thanks
again
in August this year the illustrator and
author Raymond Briggs died
he was the creator of such very famous
uh and often evocative of Christmas uh
books as the Snowman uh and fungus the
bogeyman uh and Gentleman Jim and others
I'm joined Now by Juliette Nicholson uh
the author who was his friend who's
written a very lovely piece uh in our
Christmas edition
about Raymond Briggs um it's under the
headline Juliet father curmudgeon uh
which I think Bob's a little bit unfair
on the piece but it does reflect that he
was not what you might call full of the
joy of Christmas is that fair to say
Raymond couldn't stand Christmas
it was his sort of worst time of year
um and Illustrated actually always in
the um Christmas cards that he sent me
which were sort of series of I don't
know if I if I hold one up here is one
choice one
funeral costs keep Rising this is my
Christmas card from him and inside it
says better hurry up then
um and uh and then there was another one
that was uh here we are
um
oh gosh uh
I've got so many of them here we are
it's a completely sort of I think it's
Lithuanian I'm not sure it's a picture
of Raymond on the front but inside it
says
are you lacking in energy forgetful
depressed unable to sleep anxious of
course you are it's Christmas written in
reference writing well you uh let's talk
about how you met him you met him when
you were working for uh his publisher I
think uh and he would refer to you as
blowing publicity what was it blooming
publicity women it was uh in the 1970s
and he'd already started to make a bit
of a name came from himself
with Father Christmas I mean more than a
bit of the name he he had started out as
an illustrator for other people's books
and for
um collections of fairy stories and so
on and then someone said to him why
don't you have a go and do it on your
own and so his father Christmas this
so-called curmudgeon
um had hit an absolute chord with
children and grown-ups alike uh with a
picture of Father Christmas on the loo
before he sets off on his great journey
for that night and so on
um and so we knew that as Publishers
that we had already somebody very
original a voice perhaps in the
tradition if you could call it that sort
of Roald Dahl who was doing the
subversive that children were just
suddenly feeling he's talking to us we
liked we like to laugh about
you know people sitting on the loo in a
way
um
and then one day he appeared with some
artwork that puzzled us because it was
accompanied by no text
and it was a picture of a little boy
building a snowman
and his editor Julia McRae said well
Raymond we can't you know we where's the
text is it is it on its way there is no
text
these words these pictures are words in
themselves and of course this magical
magical story The Classic perhaps
children's story for Christmas now
uh of a little boy who builds a snowman
who comes to life and she flies over the
countryside in which Raymond himself
lived so there is the Brighton Pavilion
you know there there are the Downs of
Sussex Raymond's own home
immediately the sort of identifiable
magic so therefore it became much more
real because it was linked to real life
real recognition life magic within one's
own life
and uh so he he insisted no words and
there it was published wordless and
beautiful
do you think that I mean he wasn't one
for sentimentality at Christmas as a man
but do you think he expressed uh his
sentimentality in his art
I think he was
um a man of intense nostalgia
uh he'd grown up um his father was a
Milkman
um on whom uh it has always said he
based Father Christmas himself
um his mother was a bit uh Pusher she
was a ladies maid and they'd fallen in
love and they'd lived
in the aftermath of the second world war
where values and
um hardship were
survivable
survivable values the values of keep
keep batting on was what he'd grown up
with and so spoiled brattery and excess
and commercialization of
Christmas or anything else uh did not
sit well with Raymond so I don't know if
you actually would say sentimentality
um much more a sense of unchanging
values and not liking the world that
that we were suddenly finding ourselves
within and when he moved away from
writing children's books
um the book that he himself said that he
was proudest of was his biography his
picture biography of his parents Ethel
and Ernest
um which if nobody has read this it's it
is heartbreaking but it is also very
funny and uh yes always was the book
that he himself said that he was
proudest of so he was always looking
back to a time that was quieter and
gentler and the time of his childhood
where somehow the world didn't seem to
be running at such a fast pace someone
was full of magic
and do you think that's why the Snowman
is so uh evocative or moving for people
is is this lack of words is that is that
why he did it without words because
um actually he felt words got in the way
of
um feelings
well he wasn't her what he wasn't a
words Man actually he was he
he was very
um his words were well chosen but but
short you know and he communicated
through his art
so that was his communication he didn't
need the words of course the film that
came afterwards which she was
yeah you know he was so reluctant to go
commercial and to have this film made
the one that's always shown at Christmas
um but it is accompanied by this
heartbreaking music and I I I was in a
in a shop last week and there it is
playing on the sound system so I think
now for the sort of generation that grew
up with the film and the book The Music
does
add a kind of emotional
um intensity to it that that I I think
is is is wonderful and I think Raymond
did I think he agreed that it was it was
a lovely addition
well finally Judah you say at the end
you will be putting uh the funeral card
as you call it which you've shown us
we'll stay in the draw this year but um
do you think you'll never bring it out
again
it is definitely sad idea to bring that
um
that Christmas card out now I don't want
to think about Raymond and funerals not
this year
but I think maybe next year you know
I'll have another laugh and think of
Raymond in the sky eating a bun and
having a cup of tea and having a bit of
a laugh as he looks down on us
good for you Juliet thank you very much
indeed and a very happy Christmas
now because this is our Christmas
edition and there is a piece in our
Christmas edition the printed Edition
about Mistletoe by the brilliant Andrew
Watts uh I thought we should talk about
mistletoe Andrew mistletoe is famously
uh toxic it's a parasite uh how come
it's it's now associated with Christmas
give us a bit of the story
it is actually and um one of the people
I was trying to get in touch with to
talk about mistletoe has a website where
he sells mistletoe seeds that you can
plant and it was banned by my laptop uh
because it was uh too poisonous uh the
the uh whoever is in charge of Internet
censorship I thought you shouldn't be
able to buy toxic chemicals like
mistletoe berries
but
that's not the reason that it's the
symbol of love and it is actually quite
disgusting it's because when you squeeze
the berries they you do get this white
substance that is reminiscent right I
thought it was something I thought it
was innocent kissing
sound a lot worse than that
I thought in the era of uh me too though
missile to mistletoe might have been
banned because uh as I understand it the
tradition uh which is a sort of
Victorian tradition is that if uh you
know a woman is under the mistletoe and
a man Demands a kiss she cannot
deny him which surely is completely
unacceptable now yes although it does
seem to be done yet I mean I know lots
of people have never seen mistletoe
and it's not as popular popular as Holly
and Ivy uh
except in temporary Wells of course
it's because mistletoe only grows in
very rare parts of the country and I
live in Cornwall and you don't see it at
all and then when I drove up to
gloucestershire uh
to this Festival you see it on all the
trees particularly at this time of year
when the trees are empty of leaves you
just see these huge boughs of mistletoe
uh in in those four counties around them
the Southwest Midlands
and uh that was in the Victorian period
where all the mistletoe in the country
came from and one turn in particular
temporary Wells cornered the market they
had a huge auction and most of the
mistletoe that you see in the shops
would have come through there does
mistletoe actually kill its host is it
is it destructive to the trees on which
it grows there's some debate about that
I mean I mean if it gets too heavy then
it will break them in the wind but it
was thought in the past that it just
took water from the branches so it might
have affected its Health but wouldn't
kill it now uh scientists think that it
actually takes some sugars and other
minerals but it is definitely a parasite
um but so I mean you don't think it's
going to fake I mean do you regard it as
a pagan tradition and it is sort of
druidic as you say in your piece
um but I suppose most Christian
Traditions are the Christmas trees
fairly Pagan is it not absolutely and
most of them were invented by Charles
Dickens as indeed the customer kissing
under the mistletoe was
uh it was
um a a tradition in monmouthshire and he
in the Pickwick paper spread it around
the country uh and it was about the same
time as uh the trains were starting
and that's where the temporary Wells
mistletoe uh got the strangleholder over
the country
I think I think a lot of these uh Town
festivals they they only start
celebrating them when they stop being
important and I grew up in a village
where there's now a scarecrow festival
and when I was growing up there wasn't
but there were still scarecrows in the
fields
and I think what once the actual purpose
uh disappears people start getting more
excited about it
do you associate mistletoe with your uh
childhood memories of Christmas we don't
need to get into kissing
oh no gosh no
no my mother did not approve of that
sort of thing her children would have
thought it vulgar and imagine having to
kiss your mother
oh yeah that is bad yeah Andrew I think
we'll end it there but um happy
Christmas Happy Christmas and I hope you
avoid uh all mistletoe thank you
that is it for the year in 60 minutes
from spectator TV thank you very much
for watching I hope you've enjoyed it if
you have and you're not already a
subscriber please do subscribe by
hitting the Subscribe button at the
bottom of your screen and then hit the
Bell icon to get a reminder so that you
never ever miss an episode
I would also encourage you with all of
my heart to subscribe to The Spectator
we are the greatest magazine in the
world after all
and we are currently running an amazing
Christmas offer as I mentioned the
beginning of the show for just 12 pounds
you get 12 weeks of The Spectator in
print and online and on top of that we
throw in a bottle of Paul Rodger
champagne what could be better
thank you very much for watching I hope
that you all have a very happy 2023 and
a very very happy Christmas
[Music]